wir wollen jetzt schalten zu christina
hielt nennt sie ist im berchtesgadener
land allein erziehende mutter von zwei
kindern
ein alltag guten morgen den ich mir ja
nicht ganz so einfach vorstelle wie geht
es ihnen jetzt in der kantine
nur wenn also es ist sehr sehr schwierig
wo sie von meiner arbeit nachzugehen
natürlich aber die kinder die sind jetzt
genug betreuung die geht aber heute nur
wissen wo ich arbeite natürlich länger
gegen sprechen sind die kinder auch
wieder eine morgen gegen 13 uhr und für
die kinder ist es besonders schön und
das finde ich für mich als mama extrem
heikel weil die kinder leiden die kinder
leiden wirklich sehr darunter und aus
ihr euch auf einen anderen nutzer mit
anderen kindern im ganzen bekanntenkreis
ist es erwischt
ja das geht als mutter besonders ans
herz herunter leiden die kinder
besonders frau hätten
man kann wirklich sagen sie sind
unterfordert die dürfen nicht raus wir
haben keine weiteren sozialen kontakte
sie können sich nicht mit anderen
kindern treffen sie können nicht draußen
spielen bei den kinderspielen treffen
sich kinder mit kindern auch ganz
spontan
das ist alles nicht möglich in dieser
zeit und das ist für sie ganz schlimm
und dass man hat keine großartigen
unternehmen machen kann weil meistens
irgendwo viele menschen noch zusammen in
einer masse wassers kompletten toten ist
also die kinder sind so eingeschränkt
und das merkt man wie organisieren sie
jetzt ihren alltag gerade auch um den
kindern abwechslung zu bieten sie haben
ja keine unterstützende dürfen ja diese
auch in diesen zeiten gar nicht annehmen
ist auf sich alleine gestellt die kitas
haben zu die schulen haben zu babysitter
dürfen nicht kommen sie gestalten sie
ihren alltag hilft so gut es geht was
wir immer wieder was neues einfallen mit
unseren aktivitäten die ich alleine mit
den kindern machen kann weiß kochen seit
spielabend wir lassen uns immer gespannt
haben was einfallen und ich gebe mein
bestes
das ist unbedingt was bereitet ihnen im
moment die größten sorgen dass ich angst
habe dass es noch weitergeht über hinaus
liga 14 tage und dass die kinder in
frieden länger leiden müssen
was würde das für sie bedeuten wo ist
dann auch für sie die grenze erreicht
dass sie sagen das geht nicht mehr
wenn es jetzt nach den herbstferien die
jetzt kommen noch weitergeht dann ist
eine grenze retour sage das ist nicht
nur gerade für die kinder
was haben sie gedacht was ging in ihrem
kopf vor als sie gehört haben dass unser
gesundheitsminister sparen jetzt an
corona erkrankt ist das ist eigentlich
jeden treffen können gerade von
gesundheitsminister gehe ich davon aus
dass er penibel alle vorschriften
eingehalten hat seine maske seine
vorschriften und dementsprechend ist
keiner sicher mit 19
jetzt ist es in der region berchtesgaden
land ja so dass eben alle schulen alle
kindergärten zu haben die gastronomie
hat zu das ist für diese ferienregion
besonders schwierig shoppen gehen darf
man aber noch was geht da in ihrem kopf
vor finden sie das in ordnung
gar nicht wo entweder ganz oder gar
nicht halt aber dass man das eine wird
verboten das andere ist weiterhin
erlaubt ist für mich nicht
nachvollziehbar die gastronomen leiden
in fenster runter und wenn man den
vergleich zieht fällt wie gesagt so
friseurin et cetera wo der menschen
kontakt auch sehr nah ist die haben
geöffneten auf einkaufstour jeden und
alles das ist keine ferne
tut mir leid können sie das
nachvollziehen dass das bundeskabinett
weiter tagen darf also nicht alle in
quarantäne müssen diese regeln würden ja
durchaus für andere menschen gelten
und das ist genau das was mich
eigentlich gesagt am meisten ärgern tut
weil ich sehen uns in der verantwortung
so zu handeln wie sie es von uns auch
schon langsam wo ein corona infizierter
ist wie können wir erstmal geschlossen
aber müssen zum test bis das positive
und negative ergebnis dass klassen wo
ein kind krank ist müssen zu hause
bleiben
wir müssen uns an die vorschriften
halten und dir selbst umgehen dies
obwohl wir uns auch penibel an alles
halten und das ist nicht in ordnung also
hole ist deutlich wo gefühl zu haben sie
dennoch vertrauen jetzt wenn sie sitzen
in dieser so arg betroffenen region
welches gadeland in bad reichenhall um
genau zu sagen
fühlen sie sich quasi gut aufgehoben
vertrauen sie dem krisen management
unserer regierung gerade
natürlich hätte ich mein vertrauen da
rein das ist klar aber trotzdem ist die
angst immer da und ich denke die wird
dadurch dass es so extrem durchgesetzt
und noch mehr gestört unter den wünschen
und einigen anderen personen gezählt
sowie mit den hamsterkäufen das alles
wieder losgeht und jungen merkmal
richtig und das ist kontraproduktiv
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren